so have you seen this clip going around
lately Emily where' you get McDonald's
McDonald's give me a fry is that
how you ask please give me a fry
this clip is from a 3-minute Indie anime
pilot called class of 09 but if we go
back further we see that this pilot is
actually a spin-off product from an
indie visual novel also called class of
09 but if we go back even further this
guy has been around for years putting
out comedy videos and scripts that also
make their way around the internet
especially the most oppressed group of
all gamer so Flash Forward to now and
not only has he produced this 3-minute
test pilot but he is also running a
Kickstarter to fund a longer up to
30-minute pilot episode for the project
after 30 minutes of quick wit legitimate
animation and voice acting that sounds
like actual human people you can make
characters in Grand Theft Auto do I look
like a who would know the pipeline
from SpongeBob on Wii U videos to
funding an entire team of key animators
ads and everything in between at a fair
wage is the sort of thing that I wish I
could see more often in this industry